18 semaines de mobilisation un vrai
marathon qui en ait soufflé beaucoup à
dijon ils étaient moins de 1000 à
exprimer leur colère pour eux l'objectif
est de rester visible tant que nouvelle
mange pas tant que le disque ou duo
nommant elle même n'est pas de raison
que la mobilisation des ce et pourtant
difficile parfois de rester motivé dans
un dialogue de sourds semble s'être
installée entre gouvernement et gilet
jaune mais tous les moyens sont bons
pour se faire entendre
maintenue ça représente les violences
policières avec l'écho car les la
liberté de parole qui et puis trop
attribué en ce moment on veut que ça
continue et mais on veut que ça s'arrête
parce qu'on me faire entendre
justement que ça change que le
gouvernement entende
j'ai espoir mais de moins en moins après
avoir défilé dans les rues de la ville
le cortège des gilet jaune s'est rendu à
la gare
si à dijon la manifestation s'est
déroulée dans le calme à paris de
violents affrontements entre gilet jaune
et forces de l'ordre ont éclaté
le truc c'est qu'on a l'impression que
le gouvernement n'entend que la violence
emmanuel macron après la parole après
l'acte iv le moment à paris où est au
pari était en feu les gilets jaunes se
demande au bout d'un moment si a pas que
la violence que le gouvernement entend
quoi pour beaucoup de manifestants
pas question d'abandonner maintenant je
viens aussi pour les jeunes pour la vie
des jeunes je trouve que leur vie va pas
être facile si ça continue comme ça à
gagner le smig ce ya quand même des
jeunes qui ont des niveaux d'études
quand même assez important et qui
gagnent le smic en ce moment et c'est
vraiment pas normal et ça c'est il ya
beaucoup de choses à revoir dans notre
pays
en fin d'après-midi le groupe s'est
dispersé rendez-vous est déjà donné pour
samedi prochain